enfin parmi les plus directement
concernés par ce report il ya les
responsables du planning familial
ils protestent contre cette décision
comme l'a expliqué dans un thème 2010
l'une de ses représentantes
pour elle il s'agit d'une mesure
essentiellement politique une mesure
politique certainement mais de quel
ordre s'est fractionné
sauf que des suppositions on sait que
vont les femmes prêtres qui seront
pénalisés que les femmes les plus
défavorisés muni le seront aussi
mais pour nous un planning on avait déjà
prévu
une manifestation à l'automne pour
soutenir le gouvernement je crois qu'il
faut quand même qu'on se situe bien il
n'est pas question d'être dans
l'opposition au gouvernement sur cette
mesure là on voulait le soutenir et
soutenir les parlementaires dans leur
démarche pour pour le remboursement des
dg aujourd'hui avec cette nouvelle cette
annonce je pense que cette manifestation
aura lieu de toute façon avec des
organisations de gauche mais qu'elle
n'aura plus le même objet et que ce sera
avec peut-être une manifestation de
pression pour avancer parce que là il
s'agit d'un report on aimerait bien que
ce report soit le plus
pour possible parce qu'il n'y a aucune
garantie pour l'instant nous on n'a
aucune garantie non profil